you posted something online that's real
I thought it couldn't be real it's a
video of an 80s instructional dance
stupidest [ __ ]
and it is it's from probably like 1983
or something and I was looking at us
thinking no this is a parody that
someone did this really well it's
absolutely real absolutely and it's how
to dirty dance yes you should we show
this to the people yo look at this this
is with the hips and complete contact
circle that hits the counterclockwise
keep your weight centered between your
feet
notice the upward accent when the
forward part of the circle the man
starts this movement by bending his
knees to drop down just a little bit
pulling the woman's hips in very tight
against him the afro tilt this is
possibly the most familiar movement that
most couples know right of course and
remember relax and have fun why is it
the name afro tilt through me way off
that's what pulled me in the old afro
till late you know earlier in the
segment you had me convinced I shouldn't
be dancing in clubs I think you're wrong
once I saw bring out the Afro to be on
their selfless come to Brian's at the
club doing the afro - by himself
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I really want that I want it to be in
like a tabloid a red-haired comedian did
the f rope-tow alone in a cloud for four
hours it's still out whether it's
problematic or not his Tablas $7